.
- Oui bonsoir, Mme Lacroix.
- Merci d'être là. On voit
de l'inquiétude un peu partout
dans le monde. Plusieurs pays
qui ont refermé leurs
frontières, qui ont rehaussé
les mesures. Est-ce qu'on
raison de s'inquiéter autant
de ce nouveau variant?
- Bien écoutez, on a un peu
raison parce qu'on a appris
de nos erreurs passées et donc,
quand on voit quelque chose de
nouveaux émerger quelque part,ie
des mesures pour essayer de
le contenir le plus possible.
Mais ce qu'on peut dire, c'est
que, vous savez, l'Afrique
du Sud, il y a déjà un variant
qui a émergé. L'Afrique du Sud,
c'est un pays propice à
l'émergence des variants à cause
de la population, la densité,
à cause des conditions sociales
et sanitaires, à l'occasion, qui
peuvent ne pas être très bonnes.
Et ce variant-là a surtout
émergé dans la province
du Gauteng, qui vince
de Johannesbourg. Donc, la plus
grande ville en Afrique du Sud.
Et ce variant-là a aussi déplacé
en partie le variant Delta
en termes, si vous voulez,us vo,
d'efficacité. Donc, ce qui
montre que c'est un variant
qui est capable d'être très
transmissible. Cela...
- Hum-hum... L'Organisation
mondiale de la santé qui se dit
préoccupée par ce nouveau
varian
- Tout à fait. Et en plus de ça,
ce qu'il faut comprendre, c'est
que c'est un variants qui
se propagent en Afrique du Sud
à une période de l'année où,
théoriquement, étant dans
l'hémisphère sud, l'Afrique
du Sud est en train de sor
si vous voulez, de leur
printemps pour entrer dans leur
été, alors que nous, nous
sortons de notre automne pour
entrer dans notre hiver.
Alors, ce n'est pas la saison
des virus respiratoires, en
théorie. Ils sont presque
otre été. Alors,
ils devraient être dans leur
période d'accalmie et on voit
que ce virus-là est en train
de se propager. Ce virus-là aprs
gens qui sont immunodéficients.
Vous savez que l'Afrique du Sud
est un pays où il y a beaucoup
de patients atteints du VIH.
Pas tous sont traités.
Et souvent, les patients VIH
qui peuvent être porteurs de
ce genre de viruait
avec d'autres virus, peuvent
excréter le virus pendant de
très longues périodes de temps,
ce qui permet au virus
d'acqurtain nombre
de mutations et d'arriver à
un virus qui est très changeant,
donc, un variant. Un variant,
c'est un virus qui a eu beaucoup
de mutations. Eta
à peu près la particularité
d'avoir une trentaine de
mutations, notamment à
qui sont importants pour
s'attacher sur les cellules
humaines. D'où, si vous voulez,
l'inquiétude qu'il peut y avoir
au niveau des di
organismes sur la planète.
- Et il semble se propager
rapidement. C'est la première
fois depuis Delta qu'on parle
autant d'un nouvt.
L'autre inquiétude qu'on a,
c'est de savoir : est-ce
qu'il est résistant aux vaccins
qu'on a réussis à développer
on a maintenant?
- Alors oui, c'est en réalité
la grande inquiétude.
On ne le sait pas encore.
On n'a pas de données précises.
On va voir comment les choses
vont évoluer. Il y a quand même
des gens en Afrique du Sud qui
ont reçu différents vaccins.
Beaucoup de vaccins
d'AstraZeneca entre autres.
Mais aussi certains vaccins
à ARN. Et on va voir comment
les gens vaccinés avec
ces différents vaccins-là vont
être protégés contre ce
Ce qui est aussi important de
savoir, c'est que le génie est
un peu sorti de la bouteille.
Parce que sachant que le virus
est enu Sud, sachant
qu'il y a plusieurs pays
africains d'Afrique australe qui
sont déjà touchés et sachant que
beaucoup de pays africains n'onr
ces variants rapidement, il est
fort possible que beaucoup
d'autres pays africains ait déjà
ce variant présent sur leur
territoire. Le fait que
plusieurs pays du Moyen-Orient,
qu'en Belgique, possiblement
en Grande-Bretagne, on ait déjà
détecté ce variant également...
Vous savez que la Belgique est
un pays qui a beaucoup de liens
avec le Congo parce que...
la république démocratique
du Congo. Donc, à ce moment-là
est-ce que le vaitititititititit
déjà présent dans ce pays-là,
qui est un géant démographique
de l'Afrique et qui pourrait
donc être, à ce moment-là, unee?
- Et ici aussi, on se pose
la question. Pour l'instant,
bon, au point de presse,
cet après-midi, le ministre de
la Santé Duclos disait que, bon,
pour lofficielleofficielleoffic,
il y a pas de cas recensé
au Canada. Mais est-ce que
le variant pourrait déjà
être présent ici?
- C'est une possibilité.
Je pense que personne ne peut
l'écarter. Mais ça ne veut pas
dire qpas paniqupas paniqupas p,
au contraire. Je pense que c'est
pour ça que c'est important
d'avoir des mesures
de surveillance au niveaudes di,
donc qu'on continue de faire
de la surveillance génétique,
si vous voulez, de l'empreinte
de ces virus-là pour savoir si
ces virus-là arrivent dans notre
environnement ou pas. Et c'est
très important parce que ça va
nous permettre, ce système
d'aler
nouveaux variants qui pourraient
devenir potentiellement
problématiques. Et quand je dis
problématiques, ça veut dirematé
des vaccins.
- Oui, voilà, c'est ça.
Et peut-être aussi sur les
médicaments qu'on est en traind,
notamment.
- Oui, alors, les médicaments,
c'est moins un problème parce
s médicaments-là
risquent d'avoir un peu plus
d'efficacité. Par contre, il y a
des thérapies qu'on appelle
les anticorps monoclonaux, doncs
médicaments injectables qu'on
donne aux gens malades pour
aller neutraliser en quelque
sorte le virus. C'est comm
sorte de vaccin, mais qui est
temporaire. Et à ce moment-là,
ces anticorps monoclonaux
qui sont disponibles et
commert,
très utiles pour réduire la
maladie sévè
qui sont pas hospitalisés, mais
qui ont des facteurs de risque.
Si ce virus-là se propage
de façon importante dans notre
environnement, en effet, ces
molécules-là pourraient devenir
Mais je vous
dirais, la grande question,
et pour l'instant, on ne le sait
pas, c'est : est-ce que les
vaccins vont continuer à garder
leur efficacité? Ce qui est
encourageant, c'est qu'en dépit
d'avoir vu toutes ces mutations,
avec, vous savez, vous vous
rappelez, bien s
Delta, mais le virus Alpha
avant et d'autres variants,
les vaccins, en tout cas les
vaccins ARN, ceux qu'on a
s au Canada,
que ce soit Moderna ou Pfizer,
sont des vaccins qui, à date,
tiennent bien la route et
continuent de garderleur effica.
- Espérons que ce soit la même
chose dans ce cas-ci.
C'est ce qu'on va savoir donc
au cours des prochaines
semaines, j'imagine, avec
les études qui sont déjà
sûrement en cours ou sur
le point de l'être?- Oui, tout a
prendre au moins quelques
semaines avant de savoir
qu'est-ce qui va se passer.
Il va falloir aussi, surto
en Europe, en Europe, vous savez
qu'ils connaissent une activité
très intense du virus
actuellement. Il va falloir
qu'ilsait
pas plus de ces souches-là
qui ont débarqué dans leur
environnement. Et là aussi, on
verra s'il y a une propagationa.
Mais vous savez, pour un virus,
tout ça, un  variant, c'est tout
à fait normal et naturel.
C'est une adaptation du virus
à son environnement et on va en
voir d'autres, des comme ça.
- Qu'est-ce que
mesures qui ont été annoncées
par Ottawa aujourd'hui, entre
autres, de fermer les frontières
aux voyageurs provenant des
frique australe,
donc vraiment de la région de
l'Afrique du Sud? Est-ce que
c'est suffisant? Bon, un cas
qui a été détecté également enBt
fermer la porte à davantage
de pays ou rehausser
nos mesures ici?
- Non, je pense qu'on a...
Le système qui a été annoncé
est un bon système. On peut
se réjouir de la vitesse
de réponse, je vous dirais,
du gouvernement fédéral à mettre
en place ces mesures. Je pense
que ça démontre
une évolution dans la pensée
de la façon dont on approche
les choses. Quand on se compare
à ce qui se passait au débutlore
les frontières n'étaient pas
fermées...
- On a beaucoup appris et, très
rapidement, on a mis en place
des mesures pour justement
limiter la propagationielle de e
virus-là. Le fait d'avoir aussi
des systèmes dans différentes
provinces de surveillance
au point de vue génétique
des différents virus qui
circulent au Canada, qui
sont des systèmes d'alerte,
si vous voulez, nous permettent
aussi
en live, on dira, là, donc,
de façon continue et actualisée.
- En temps réel, le plus
rapidement possible.
- En temps réel, tout à fait.
De l'émergence de ces virus-lào.
Donc, je vous dirais qu'au
Canada, on a quand même un bon
système de surveillance au
niveau de la structure globale
que ce soit au niveau fédéral
ou au niveau des provinces.
Et le fait d'ê
rapidement...
- Oui, c'est ça, ils sont
intervenus rapidement.va possib.
Mais en même temps, Dr Weiss,
en terminant, tout ça, ça nous
ramène à l'importance de réduire
les inégalités vaccinales
entre les pays, finalement,
pour éviter qu'il y ait
tant d'autres mutations aussi
importantes?
- Oui, mais il y a aussi
d'autres défis par rapport à ça.
Il y a tout le défi de la
logistique, il y a
l'acce
des vaccins dans certains pays
où les populations ne veulent
pas forcément être vaccinées.
Donc, il y a énormément de justr
des vaccins dans certains pays,
c'est aussi le fait qu'ils
puissent être adéquatement
distribués et que lespopulations
à les recevoir. Parce qu'il y a
des pays où les gens ne sont pas
très enclins à vouloir se faire
vacciner. Et com
à date, l'immense majorité des
vaccins des pays... On a parlé
du variant indien, on a parléfr,
du variant brésilien, donc
des pays, souvent, où vous avez
souvent des gros poids
démographiques, vous avez
des zones aussi où il y
problèmes sociaux, sanitaires.
Alors, on peut malheureusement
se dire que dans la grande ville
de Johannesburg, de plusieurs
millio
les townships, de Johannesbourg,
il y a, je vous dirais,
des conditions propices à
l'émergence de ces variants danu
il y a une densité démographique
très élevée et aussi où il y a
des patients qui sont atteints,
par exemple, du VIH pas traitéez
une facilité pour ces variants
d'émerger dans ce contexte.
- Une armée de scientifiques
certai
tout ça présentement à travers
le monde. Dr Karl Weiss, merci
infiniment d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir.
- Ça me fait plaisir!
Bonne soirée!